nonsense car tester Sascha cannot
remembers all the attention Mercedes
attracted when they introduced their 8th
class in 1997 one of the first mini MPV
a 3rd generation has little left in
common with what appeared on the market
back then commas that might tend to work
in its favor if it's going to appeal to
a younger generation of car buyers the
new addition has considerably greater
appeal to Sascha at least unlike the
second generation this is a sporty car
in the compact segment the a-class can
easily hold its own with a VW Golf and
the Audi a3 for the audio delightful
setting we tested the a 200
gasoline-powered version with a maximum
speed of 224 km/h it makes the sprint
from 0 to 100 in 8.4 seconds and takes
just 5 point 4 liters of fuel per
hundred kilometers
on the outside the new a-class has had a
complete makeover from its predecessor
just as the Mercedes designers promised
under the hood is a four-cylinder direct
injection engine it's also lower by
about 16 centimeters points out Sasha
quite noticeable when getting into the
car it's no longer as accommodating to
older drivers as it is to the younger
and nimbler a dynamically contoured body
with distinctive lines make for a sporty
ER look 17-inch alloy wheels are
standard the emphasis on width and
horizontal lines in the rear makes a
muscular impression reinforced by the
one-piece taillights curved into the
side panels
the new a-class has well and truly
arrived in the compact segment but at
341 litres it has the segment's smallest
cargo space as sporty as the a-class
looks it would be hard-pressed to carry
even a golf bag without the backseat
folded down 1u looks it's fun cuppa mr.
the speed sensitive parameter assisted
steering lets the driver maneuver the
car easily and safely even at high
speeds the interior has also been redone
with chrome accented leather on all
sides the large interior display and the
comfortable leather seats harmonize
smoothly with the whole there's no
shortage of safety and assist systems to
choose from weather lane departure
warning or active Blind Spot Assist
every option is available
summing it all up now that the new
a-class has shed its stodgy look and
feel for a sporty er design Sasha can op
is one over if only the price weren't so
high though the a 200 we tested would go
for some 27,000 euros and that's even
without extras like the sat-nav or any
of a variety of assists the high
starting price of around 24,000 300
euros in Germany might scare off younger
buyers but the design